二月だけど
あツアー
それじゃあ自走である時の皆さんも10月なんですけども気づきましたでしょうか
あっあぁ俺ら怒ってる頭はおかしくないですか立って10月てもさんとした秋なのに
まだ半袖ても言ってるけれどの温度逆に今を夏なんですねまだいうことで今日は
スイカ割りしていきたいと思います私は思ったんですけどもうスイカ割りあの余裕なん
ですよ馬鹿でもできる
すいか割りというのは目隠しされて市場誰かに出されてスイカをたたきくるくるんだ
けども
pou dou dou からそりゃあヌー
[音楽]
voodoo
痛い気に入ってっ
トップ
そのまま下に振り下ろしください
おらあああ正負いいんですねまじ塗る4 s ゲー
兵部がわかってそんなにバカじゃない人であればいい母になったこと誰でもできるん
ですがそこで私は思ってもっと楽しいスイカ割りはできないかと言える今日は日本の
以外の言葉をしゃべれる人たくさん読んでみました
どうぞ
[音楽]
いやー
航空機で日本語でスイカ割りしても理由でできるって事は他の言葉だと難しくなるん
じゃないか説をやってみようと思いますみなさん日本語以外しゃべれるんですか
うーんちょっとわけじゃないぞやあ
どこの国か聞いてみましょうわっち部 language
ブルースピークときどいったじゃあにやボール電球
問屋で何誤差縁ます歓迎旅館がいいですね
ねあんだよあれじゃ何語を喋るんでスター推理し
うぇーんですね o 2号されるんですか買えなくて
ウクライナ沿いうげえあればと思います2号されるんですか
イタリアーノ開いたりアロアのインターでライターやっ追走
in アンケート nc 後あインドメジャーをよろしくお願いします
何語をしゃべるんですか
ブーブー日本語と英語ある程度わかるんで日本語と英語以外のポットばをみんなに指示
を出してアドバイスもらいながら今日明日以下は利用していきたいと思いますウエイク
オーダーロス
優雅 f って一味上祝来校
5 live your
language ん
アップ先輩でしたはっはあああああ
セルライトこれ
英語さえ早くなんのって
[音楽]
んですかー
ああああああ5 sd 5
me ok
ブーブーブーブーエラーし
ブーブー j
[音楽]
dj dan
re j しー j
[音楽]
うわあああああああ
オーデータ
dare no day
nao
ブーブー jr rocrew sej
ano 1
voodoo
alejandro o
dj dj
car
ana
わからん
[音楽]
me
teame
ana あああっ
だ難しかったあれ常に右ってなんていいます
あげました
ラヴァル提言
左左は dje ran
前はふんっはいあーおれん
後ろアナティこれこれわかんねーよ